[Music]
is it racist news probably if you have
to ask that question that no is it
racist or racist submitted by I love
doing oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't
know if those like okay it gets a bad
one okay good Ian I have no idea oh yeah
you very punish officious you should try
it party the tape is not that bad it's
just that the smell comes out and it
just move yeah I need I think it tastes
like garlic
mango nothing that's yeah kind of with a
bit of heart a little bit of fart a lot
of aren't you with your mouth when you
taste it doesn't taste as bad as it
smells
mm-hmm mix thanks tofu it tastes like
Chevron made it does it taste worse or
better than a little bit like by a hair
smell makes it unbearable there's no
[ __ ] way I could eat a white guy is
suing a Hong Kong firm after being
called way low by his colleagues while
oh it's [ __ ] written in Latin oh you
can read Jamie that's not China nothing
like you can reach I mean I couldn't
read it cuz it's in like Latin letter
yeah that's still all truth you could
read it if it wasn't Chinese
is it racist yeah let's put his ass on
trial I didn't know that guano was a
racist term I thought that just white
yeah it means so quiet ghosts ghosts /
devil and a low means man so a literal
devil man ghostly / devil man yeah and
then it means like white devil so what's
the correct term of white people
Caucasians they're like a caucasian word
a moose arm but Amanda wouldn't be like
why person like I read I never heard of
the correct term of white person I've
always heard people call them gwai-lo
cuz it's so endearing to like in the
Kazon YZ culture talking [ __ ] is such
affectionate language yeah Olga at the
same time it's just really blunt yes
there's no funny nicknames right cuz
there's another one that's like Bach Y
or some [ __ ] like that I wish I had a
Cantonese person in there it's more
descriptive than it is like races yeah
Vietnamese will say like a white
Americans like me Jung and it's
literally like American white you would
understand that because it's descriptive
yeah or the same way like you know
Hawaiian people will call somebody like
a haole when you know that they're like
a mix between like like Asian or a white
person you know what I'm saying no is
hapa yeah Polly is a white person right
but that's the kind of drugget or it is
it depends on who you're talking to
it's always descriptive yeah I mean yeah
I don't know again maybe I'm being
Internet to it no in Hong Kong Julien
British Australian man he was working
for this company and he was in charge of
a project and he said that he was
discriminated because he didn't speak
Chinese and that he wasn't Chinese and
that they would always call him with y
lo every country with white people cuz
like even in Mexico like my family looks
kind of white so whenever my sister and
her boyfriend would try to go and buy
something I mean obviously she
understand Spanish but they were like oh
just give him like the white people face
so there she's like what the [ __ ] I know
what you're saying I'm Mexican oh oh
[ __ ] my bad like yeah yeah you get the
local point this also happens everywhere
too cuz like guys in the military like
if I was with a bunch of Mexican dudes
I'm just the automatic Chino like I just
feel like it's just so normal
yeah like if you're the odd one out
they're gonna give you a bunch of still
[ __ ] up cuz everyone's doing it it's
still [ __ ] up how's it [ __ ] up
because like he's getting treated a
certain way because of the way well you
gotta earn your stripes and whatever
you're in once you earn their stripes
then you like if I can out Mexican the
other Mexican do them then I'm in it you
know I eat more Lucas than you drink I
mean you got an X in person you pretty
much should have a lot of respect yeah
so even like for like hinges right like
let's say you got the newest kinder that
just joined he has to earn he or she has
to earn their stripes but if they're
down they put in the extra hours do all
those things and it's like you're like
oh [ __ ] respected this guy I don't think
it's just a race thing that thing is
like earning that Brotherhood thing
thank you man you did that like an old
Asian man like hey you just spoke the
truth you know I just I felt it all
right
he ended up being dropped on the project
yeah cuz he's not man enough to handle
earning the Chinese Brotherhood
this [ __ ] guy lo little [ __ ]
complaining can't even call him a couple
names
you ain't gonna last sensitive [ __ ] well
it's interesting because there's people
that are quite loathe in Hong Kong they
feel like it's not a derogatory term
that because I under strike they earn
the [ __ ] incense and their moon cakes
so like when you say like Wetty
or widow is that derogatory or is that
literally just white white girl on like
a blonde person but like me like my
family calls me flaca which is like
skinny girl yeah and they call me pretty
a thought which is like a dark girl
while oh just met foreigner well it
started off as a derogatory term
according to what I'm reading and
they're saying that it was when the
British took over Hong Kong I'm still
calling white lows for likes coming
bombarding their nation and like
stealing their culture yeah I think I'd
have a little bit of resentment - yeah
but then it turned and it turn into an
endearment yeah in that culture like if
my dad goes to a restaurant and he meets
someone for the first time back he
immediately starts calling boss like hey
what's up boss or hey best friend
like it's it's a very affectionate and
inclusive thing so when you meet someone
you're like oh you [ __ ] all beer or
your blood hey you [ __ ] cracker-ass
why it's very like inclusive and societ
hugs alright you translate some words it
just doesn't work because like sometimes
you call someone fat ass but that means
like like you yeah yeah but then yeah
yeah like in in that one Netflix movie
with the work the war thing with Brad
Pitt laureen's bastard no no the other
one the the Netflix fairy no no I don't
know anyways uh there's a moment where
like you know they're in the Middle East
and the guys like why do you call us
like [ __ ] you know in my
country is not good - like [ __ ] mothers
and he's like no no no no no in our
country it's not good to [ __ ] mothers
either yeah you know what I mean but
it's just like it's terminology so like
maybe there is like a literal
translation of like devil man or
whatever but like yes ain't yeah yeah
they're just using the DES see if he's
mad enough to stripes that's like if you
you know with some time to talk to your
friends you'll be like hey [ __ ]
okay call Jessa [ __ ] right now or like
when she walked in you're like yeah yeah
hey [ __ ] you're like whatever so it's I
think it depends on intent and there's
so much context that that goes on you
know and I think it happens in most um
ethnic culture like in most uh I guess
walkies from the UK or the British
Australian oh but like in Mexican
culture like you call you call people by
their insecurities or like if they're
fat you're gonna call them fat and
that's a good term of endearment yeah my
mom is a huge roaster I like white
people can get away with that though you
know what I mean like no one feels bad
we can't be like you can't be you can't
tell black people like hey well we don't
start off like that you know what I mean
like like as soon as we meet someone of
course we're gonna be cordial and polite
but it's like as soon as you start kind
of building a relationship then you can
start [ __ ] around it's not like off
the bat like hey what's up fatso you
know what I mean like that's not how it
is it seems like in this case so they
didn't have that relationship with him
because he was upset by it so he just
probably just walks into this project
and they just keep calling him quite low
by little whatever and then he gets
booted out and so or he's just someone
that gets butthurt really it was also
saying that they would often arrange
meetings on the days like he was off
like little things like that was kind of
[ __ ] up yeah there's just a lot of
context that we don't understand and I
know he might just feel like like left
out and and he might is he could be that
uptight [ __ ] that like just doesn't
fit in and they're just like oh man this
fool is just all bad vibes like because
I don't think it's white or non-white
think it's more like maybe blue colored
and like you know
uppity you like white colored so this
was doing business in another country
right and I just liked that Brotherhood
concept its transcends cultures so I
could totally see anybody it could be a
Filipino guy a Mexican guy Chinese guy
or even black guy whatever like if they
did business in Korea I wouldn't be
surprised if one of the first dinner
meetings was eating the raw octopus see
if they're mad enough to join that like
this should put them in the [ __ ]
first extreme I tested
you have to test it and then so either
you're gonna be a endeared gwai-lo
or they're gonna keep picking on you
because you are man enough to eat
octopus I completely agree that that's
like a normal thing and that's cool and
that's like a manly thing or whatever
but I'm just like kind of pointing out
though like if a white company did that
to literally any other color it would be
bad
I do you think like historically though
like why people have done that more to
everyone apparently not because it's so
much in the culture right that it's like
he's expecting that you'd be like they
do it to each other well no because it's
a form of fraternizing you know no I
mean and why culture does also have that
yeah so that's why I think it's weird
that this guy just felt like you
couldn't connect with that like like
understanding like all this well I just
think it's like a sensitive dude yeah
for sure yeah cuz in white culture like
guys that rose guys that like like in
the military all the time but that's
just a culture that existed it's not one
group or the other yeah I just think
it's like cuz for example there are
uptight ass Asians that can't deal with
this [ __ ]
either they can't be roasted they can't
deal with it and then it's just easy I
think the difference is if it was a
white company and a minority was feeling
like an Asian guy right even if they are
sensitive or whatever right it doesn't
go both ways
because of the history part it doesn't
know everything u.s. in the u.s. every
single little dick a little a small eyes
[ __ ] math knowing like any of those
dog eating Zoey yeah I heard every
single one of those jokes right but if I
completed a 15-mile hike with them and I
was ahead of at least ten of those
[ __ ] and they're like oh [ __ ]
this falls tight so now I'm the little
dick [ __ ] density that they're
cool with yeah but I'm still gonna be
called the little dick [ __ ] I
mean and also specifically this is a
dude from the UK in Hong Kong - yeah if
brelo is ever like semi appropriate to
describe like the white UK man in the
like the nation that area of Hong Kong
you know what I'm saying like it to them
yeah like very descriptive but I could
also understand do the outsider no
matter what in this Hong Kong
company so we've been like logistically
efficient to have meetings without him
so you didn't have to translation [ __ ]
and just make moves and maybe to them
they're not like we're being racist but
there it is
maybe it's just racist yeah you know
because you know maybe they're it's
still kind of backwards yeah
multiculturalism is like it exists in
Hong Kong but then like they don't have
the same history as we do in the US so
like there's blatant risks racism that
exists in Asia and that's because they
didn't go through the same history that
we did here so the whole context I think
is different depending on where you're
at
yeah you can't bring the pains of
whatever happened like in the u.s. to
another country yeah and act as if it's
the same thing
guiley I kind of feel bad for the guy in
the UK guy because he's just a fish out
of water trying to make things work in a
different country and he's like you know
getting hazed maybe he just doesn't know
how to communicate but I mean that's
just how the world is right now you know
like it's it's you you got a you got a
Masoli maneuver and and also regardless
of where you are being a white company
or any of that you can't play the same
thing that everyone else can just
because of how history played out
[Music]
[Music]